Did you see the Outer Co Colby?
Covington? No. What did he do?
What he said about John Jones?
I don't even want to hear
it. No. Okay. We shouldn't,
I mean you could, you could bring it
up if you want to, but it was talking,
it was a, it was, uh, like a, a text
like this just about John Johnson,
how a piece of shit is
now.
I was even surprised when I saw
it myself, you know, I was like,
is this right or wrong?
I don't know.
Jon Jones going to be in front
of you one day. Gotta be careful.
Watch your fucking words.
Yeah.
You gonna get slapped in the face by a
guy can kill you with his hands. That's a,
that's a bad move. I, I get
what Colby is doing. I mean,
he's making a lot of noise and
trying to do business, you know,
and if you fight him,
you going to make a lot of money because
a lot of people gonna come to see him
get his ass kicked,
you know?
You know he ain't going to find out that
he's not probably on, on the, on the,
on the popper list is probably on the,
I want you to see,
I want to see you get knocked out list.
He's in a dangerous situation right now.
He's gonna Fight Dos Anjos. Yeah. How
failed though? San Joses Brazilian.
He talked crazy shit about Brazil
and they were gonna fight in Brazil.
You can move the fight in Chicago.
Which Colby thank the baby Jesus exec.
I would say the same thing.
You don't want to be fighting Hofeld does
on Joe's. You don't really want to me,
you'd only want back close to president.
Right. And I feel credible coming from,
you don't even want to be close to
him. No, I would not go. If I was him,
he'd probably go anyway,
man. He doesn't give a fuck.
He'll go off the money's right.
I'm sure he would,
but dos Santos right now at
welterweight I think is a murderer.
He's a fucking killer at welterweight
because for him that cut down to 55 was
just too big, too big. And
now he's a big guy. He's big,
but it's just too much of a
cot to draining on his body.
And then you see the way he beat Robbie
Lawler in his last fight. You're like,
Holy Shit.
Goes through Neil Magni,
Robbie Lawler and you'd look at how
good he looks at me. One seven. Yeah.
It's a good fight. It's a good
fight. Is a very good food. Yeah.
It's a really good fight.
Particularly stand up.
He has a big advantage I think over Colby.
Standup. What does he do? Called beam,
but it says wrestler. It's a rest.
He's a restaurant. Yeah. Okay. Yeah,
it's standup is good. I mean, he
beat Damien Maia. I beat him up.
But I feel like my, uh, is uh, you know,
I mean my was coming off of that very,
very hard fight against Tyron Woodley.
Five hard rounds got beat up
and then he's going to go five.
Or I think he went
three rounds with Colby,
but I just don't think
he's the same guy anymore.
I think he's 41 I think my very long time,
long days being in the game
for a very long time. Yeah.
And I think, uh, those long,
hard five round war, it's like you
did with takes a toll on you. Yeah.
It takes a toll on not taking
anything away from Colby,
but I think also think Colby
style is probably tailored,
married for a guy like Maya. Yeah.
You know, wrestling very strong.
What you usually see, like your breasts
and Gans Brazilian Jujitsu guys.
Yeah.